so last night I fell asleep at the
University of Exeter but this isn't my
room and this is an Exeter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the University of Exeter actually has
several campuses as to an extern then it
has one here which is Penrhyn which is
in Cornwall what are you wearing
[Laughter]
yeah now if you listen to the wiki cast
which is Danone eyes new podcast yeah
you're gonna know about this building
that we're visiting because where are we
done
sure a cathedral yeah I can't fit it all
in so we're here at Chartres Cathedral
because Chapel Choir is singing for all
the graduation ceremonies at University
of Exeter now we did 15 ceremonies last
week which I would have logged but it
would have killed me to do it and we're
here to do the ones in pairing campus
thank you ad natural Cathedral isn't in
Penryn it's in Truro but this is
basically to good ability to university
to pass up on so they ship everybody
over here and so that they can have a
nice ceremony in here and also so that
we can sing in here so we're here in the
song school which is underneath the
Cathedral people's right so we're here
in the song school underneath the Drule
and things happening right up there
there's a pretty cool bulge of it so
we're getting ready to do the first
ceremony oh nice we've been comparing
what music they have like compared to
Exeter they've got some good stuff in
here
[Music]
houses burn any day thank for our first
performance look that's done oh this is
what a Catholic that held up and you've
got Gracie got Tallulah got Lucy em your
Bethel and Catherine apparently
Catherine's had some issues with this in
the past
Daniel that's a mighty nice sweater
you're wearing yeah
don't you dare think that you know what
it says comeback point out that I
pointed that out what did you point out
cuz he's gonna turn indoor trademark and
it's now like broken his heart and
that's hilarious it's not real done
Harry pastas not real so the way that
these days have been working because
we've done this last week as well is
that we will sing for hours five to ten
minutes start the ceremony and then all
the important people come in and they
start giving out their degrees and then
we go backstage and we went to the next
ceremony and they do three of the day so
you have a couple of hours wait between
ceremonies which means that I sing take
the Rings off and then get to work I'm a
weird point at the moment where I feel
like my coding has never been more
powerful like I've never understood
programming and the programs that I
write better but at the same time I feel
like I don't understand why things are
happening probably and what confuses at
any point in my PhD so we're trying to
entertain ourselves please well
oh don't just hit live in the eye
new new net please good at the vestry
underneath Tripathi was a newsman quite
like this before
next do not get involved in the game it
wasn't going over there's a wind so just
let's do the second service something I
haven't mentioned is that this is my
last day singing the chapel by
officially then he got two more services
so that we just did the penultimate
service which was a mix this time it was
handle and queen because we did a
version of Bohemian Rhapsody which is
actually on our YouTube channel on our
link down there I've recorded it I think
it came out rather well now and I got
one left so for obvious reasons I
haven't had to bring the camera on stage
with me because you know I'm singing but
I thought it'd be criminal for me to
come here and not show you guys what the
inside of this building looks like
services just finished so I'm gonna see
if I can show you guys
so I Stan and I discuss in the wiki cast
and this is the first Cathedral to be
built on a new site in England since the
1200 s this is a Victorian Cathedral one
dark which is why it looks quite gothic
it's also why it looks a lot more kind
of architectural perfect than other
cathedrals because it wasn't built over
the years and I Donst it was come
designed and built all in one go and it
sounds amazing to sing in also the organ
the organ is one of the best instruments
in the country I spoke my father Willis
who also built the organ in my college
in Oxford
you can see there's a teddy bear whoops
so I actually blogged the week of the
last service we did by him turn time but
that was part of the footage that I
deleted Paxton at this retouching
montage planned so I can't really do
that anymore but it's kind of strange
really to sort of be signing off the
chapel choir here because this is a
building of any sung in twice but if
even watching devote for a while you'll
know how much chapels meant to me and
how much it's added some university
experience and if you are a singer
applying to University of Exeter I can't
stress enough that you should apply
because it's a phenomenal ensemble from
the musical perspective but also
socially and it's made by time and X to
what it's been I wouldn't change it for
anything it's gonna be very difficult
not kinda back in September and singing
with them and I think that's probably
most people who don't sing well haven't
sung in a group for a long time won't
really understand but these guys aren't
just acquired to me they're family
I'm gonna miss them what you're doing
[Laughter]
phenomenal it's true
it's Oh
it's like pipe-cleaners sticking out the
bottom
why all have our sunglasses on to the
Hylian rhapsody none of us have meant to
have trousers on when you say men oh oh
dear lord I can't really communicate
through video how where this feels but I
can't like it's very liberating here you
go
it's no trousers Shero not no puns
Penrhyn oh god my last service Katie
2017
Karan did you make a mess
I did okay
anyone with the boat thanks to any one
of these amazing glasses hello under
social set next year but you'd never get
it's going to be what built chaos it
[Music]
[Music]
so room the way back working the truer
to x2 and we've been done singing stuff
saying stuff which needs an organ which
Peters been filling in for but also this
is what happens with a chapter on a bus
singing happen next to me Curran is
struggling to the front right now yeah
but I'm gonna need make it run but she
needs to pee badly badly I can imagine
say I told you so
off he goes
we wish you a very good buddy we are
being you peace
thank you it they actually coming yeah
I'm feeling I'm on a document in Correns
struggle with his bladder so camera yes
I will definitely have to believe the
person well we're going a different way
[Music]
he's going oh god speed current
the driver had his headphones very
firmly on in my journey here he is the
man himself
look at that swagger how was that P
Corrin it was amazing this is like the
post match interview you know I think I
performs well you know I think my beer
and I now feel how did you think the
formation affected UOP today Wow well I
still look like Sheldon now to take I'll
step back to the chapel for the last
time hasn't quite hit me yet I don't
think I have sung here every week for
three and a half years I'm still not so
good I see me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you